Apple and Ireland have won their appeal
against the European Commission over a
13 billion euro unpaid tax bill Ireland
correspondent Stephen Murphy is in
Dublin forests and Stephen a pretty
important victory for Ireland's economy
well that's a matter of debate Adam I
mean it's a victory for the Irish
government which is always denied that
it had made any favorable tax
arrangements that would favor Apple but
certainly it under surface others it
would seem pretty bizarre that any
country would try to fight against
receiving a tax windfall of 13 point 1
billion euro it's actually over 14
billion euro when you include the
interest payments but all of this dates
back to a European Commission decision
in 2016 that Ireland had favored Apple
over other companies doing business in
arms with a certain set of complicated
tax arrangements which effectively
allowed Apple to under pay its tax
obligations by as I said more than 13
billion euros around eleven point eight
billion pounds Europe then ordered our
and to recover that money from Apple but
the Irish government said it would not
do so because it had always denied that
it had favored apple in any way it was
also keen to find a perception that
Ireland could be considered some sort of
offshore tax haven so the Irish
government then underly over on for now
under Niall Martin had forced this case
to the General Court of the European
Union which this morning annulled
that original decision from 2016 that
Apple had to pay this money in that
decision today just in the in the last
half are coming from Brussels the
General Court Street that Apple had not
been granted any selective economic
advantage by Irish tax policies we found
reaction from the Irish government
straight away the Department of Finance
saying Ireland has always been clear
there was no special treatment to
provide it to Apple the correct amount
of Irish tax was charged taxation in
line with ordinary Irish taxation rules
Apple has also welcomed this news but I
mean as I alluded to there to sorry this
is not going to be a universally popular
decision against the backdrop
of an economy that has been completely
battered by the corona virus pandemic
here we have the government of the day
turning down a cash windfall from the
world's largest company of 14 billion
euro which could have been spent on
health or housing or one of the other
pressing issues this decision though it
is widely expected that the European
Commission will appeal this to the
European Court of Justice so the saga
isn't over yet that 14 billion euro is
being held in an escrow account for the
moment